and i think that the most
at least to me the most uh
important aspect is not really being uh
addressed and that's uh
uh gender equality i'm getting to a
point where we have
women in our israeli site is extremely
important to me and this is something
that we've set a goal
me and our head of a job
you should talk to her she's amazing
and uh she and and we set together a
goal to have percent women
and uh
and it's something that we we have more
than the average here in safebreach but
uh
but we wanna strive for more we wanna
get to a point where we have more
welcome to twenty minute leaders just
sit back relax and learn from the
leaders of today it's a journey each one
is different unique inspiring let's get
started
[Music]
this episode is powered by j ventures a
community driven vc fund in silicon
valley in partnership with lumitec
sponsored by homeward ventures hippo
insurance oppos labs synergy global
hillel at stanford leap birthright excel
serena partners and in media partnership
with ctec
hello hello and welcome to 20 minute
leaders today i am with ido yahov vice
president of r d and general manager of
israel at safebreach
he does safe breaches vice president of
r d and israel's general manager and
before that he served as minty ghost
vice president of r d which was acquired
by anaplan where he led the development
of the company's engineering and
research groups
prior to mint ago idol was an engineer
manager in microsoft working on several
areas such as telecom windows security
and azure
ido also has spent time in his career
leading teams at several startups mostly
networking and network security hidal
holds a bsc in computer science from the
university of bala ilan
[Music]
welcome to 20 minute leaders thank you
so much for joining me how are you
excellent thanks for having me
of course no i'm so excited so excited
to have you here edo you're today you're
vice president um of r d general manager
of israel at savebreach an incredible
company in the cyber security very deep
tech research oriented i have a lot of
friends who work there and are just so
you know fulfilled with the work that i
i can't wait to hear a little bit about
your you know the leadership behind
save breach and what you're doing there
but but even more broadly about general
leadership within tech previously head
of engineering planning aid and a plan
and general manager and vp engineering
at mintigo and manager within microsoft
and vpr d at incitix so you know a cr an
incredible journey a lot of leadership
within tech
is this always did you know this was
your calling to be an r d leader
throughout your career so
i don't know if calling is the word but
it's something you're really inspired
for something i really enjoy doing
and i'm a firm believer that people
should really do what they enjoy
um it's extremely important at least to
me um aside from
being a
part of a group of people that really
enjoy doing what they want and what they
aspire to
and uh it can be anything from uh
developing to marketing to
uh sales
anything that you know gives your spark
and and get you get you going in the
morning that's uh that's what's
important and uh all through
i've been really fortunate to have that
through most of my career uh at the
beginning obviously there were small
development positions in my area
and then i started to expand becoming
more of a
technical owner in areas and
and then i realized that i want to be
part of the leadership in companies
after i left the army i
joined startups and
it was really much easier to make an
impact in a smaller
in a smaller startup
yeah but then at some point i
i decided that i want to taste big
corporate and i wanted to join different
companies so i joined microsoft and
microsoft has been a really it's a large
company so it's a big corporate again
and um and you learn a lot um i mean
your whole perspective about what it
means to lead and what it means to uh
aim
to
own
your deliveries
um
getting to a point where you uh you
really help people grow
it's something that's really focused
alongside my career and it's something
that i really like doing mentoring
people helping people grow
and
getting them
or sort of helping them focus on what
they want to achieve in life and what's
important to them
so
that's that's been most of my journey so
far aside from the technology which is
important and it's fun but it's really
it's really people at the end of the day
you really love the people that you work
with
it it does everything
so i think that you're setting the stage
here for for a very interesting
conversation about people and how do you
you know get people today and how do you
you know
create a team that that really is a
superstar team filled with people that
you want to work with but a little bit
before that
share with me a little bit about your
thesis and your managerial style as an r
d manager
how how does how do your meetings run
how what is sort of your perspective on
you you're talking a lot about your role
so to uplift people and help them
achieve their goals what is sort of your
perception on that
so it's a great question the thing is
that uh
i do believe that uh
you have to
be part of the way people work i mean
um
let's say that we have a meeting
i
i try not to be the one really running
the meeting but i want to have everyone
owning the meeting owning the outcome
it's really important though in meetings
to have a set goal um we have tons of
meetings in
in all of our companies looking back
throughout uh throughout the years
meetings have always been something that
uh
managers need and want and engineers
want to stay away from
but if you make meetings short precise
and to the point then it gets to be much
less of a hassle more of a way to get
things done
and um
and and the way it works is that at
least for me it works for me
is that i help or organize and make sure
that things are happening
but i'm not really the only one running
the meeting if i'm the only one talking
in a meeting then that's a bad meeting
um
and
and once you have everyone collaborating
working together towards a goal and it
doesn't have to be only in a meeting
it can be any in anything
and they see the
what they want to achieve at the end
then it's uh
it's really easy for everyone to really
join forces and become
and become you know one organized group
and uh that makes my job easier at the
end of the day
so that's what i strive for
so this is obviously more relevant once
you have the team but the challenge
starts from a little bit before that
you know 2022
what is happening today there's it's
madness out there
it is it's definitely madness uh it's
really hard to uh
um
to get people on board i mean at the end
of the day
what we want is people who are
who see our culture who see our belief
we see our goals and they want to join
in they want to join forces and they
want to be part of something that we
believe is going to be amazing great big
whole company not just a hype of a word
but really something that
does something we want to be able to we
are
selling we are a having we have a viable
product we have something out there we
want people who are going to be part of
that
and it's really difficult because uh
there's a lot of buzz around there's a
lot of you know
hype about everything uh relating to not
only cyber security but everything in
the
uh in the high tech uh space
and i think that the most
at least to me the most uh important
aspect is not really being uh addressed
and that's uh
uh gender equality i'm getting to a
point where we have
women in our israeli site is extremely
important to me and this is something
that we've set a goal
me and our head of a job
you should talk to her she's amazing
and uh she and and we set together a
goal to have 50
women
and uh
and it's something that we we have more
than the average here in safebreach but
uh
but we want to strive for more we want
to get to a point where we have more so
um so we're really putting a lot of
effort into getting that done
trying to get to a point where
we address those needs and uh get become
attractive
for uh for everyone
and uh it's really important
so how do you
proactively go about doing that i mean a
lot of people are talking about you know
the gender equality and the gender gap
especially within tech
how do you actually go about it making
even the smallest proactive step into
into trying to promote this because it's
so delicate on one hand it's so
complicated on the other hand there's so
much so much complexity in the chain
from education to social perception to
eventually you know creating a culture
that that allows it how do you go about
it
so
i think we start by a
one making sure that the way we talk and
the way we address people
is uh
is is in in the address or in the in the
realm of gender equality
uh we try not to
create
um
job descriptions that uh
that
are not
that are more
male-oriented we don't want that we want
it to be general
we want
people here inside safebridge to bring
in
a
friends that's obviously that's obvious
every company does that but what we do
say and we say that almost every week
bring your friends and if you can if
they're
if they're female then that's even
better we want that
and we we encourage that
um we try to reach out to a to specific
women groups
obviously
some of them are more close towards
women so we try to have our female
employees
really involved and
try to bring in others i think it's uh
it's something that they see as a is a
really good opportunity for them to
bring in more
more gender equality into the office and
get us
to a better place i do believe that once
we get a more
into a more equal
area then we're really going to be a
better company at the end of the day
um it's um
it's really something that we have been
trying to scratch our heads and figure
out what are the best ways to do this
there is no like magic stick okay but
we're gonna
just bring everyone and everything
everything is gonna be great it's
something really what you need to work
hard in you need to make sure that uh
when people scan for cvs they don't uh
they don't
bring in
some people that they think are more
like them only
er obviously we do want people to bring
their friends but uh but we want a very
diverse
society here in uh in safe bridge it's
really important for us i believe it's
going to make us much much better
what's the differentiation in today's
market for candidates the people that
you're on boarding that are joining the
team you know if you're putting yourself
in their shoes of those that are
considering where to go
where is the differentiation really
taking place
so safewhich is really in in a unique
position we are
um
we are a company that's really
been selling to the
uh highest companies out there the the
best the biggest and best companies out
there ranging from insurance to finance
to uh
telcos automotive everything
and
what we do is we help everyone in the
company become part of that process be
it in in sales or in uh so we have
engineers helping
sales or being part of sale a
sale processes or
customer success
we're really involved there and the
entire customer journey is something
that our engineers are part of and it's
really important to have
the
everyone on board
i mentioned that before i mean once you
have everyone striving towards the same
goal and we've got the same goal we want
to make um and we can talk about what
safe pitch does but
once everyone understands what safe
breach does and we want to enable that
for our customers
then everyone just wants to make that
happen
and
and they can come up with ideas on how
to
better help them
which features are going to be relevant
there and
what technologies to use which are going
to be more relevant for what's what
we're up against
so
the entire journey is really in the
hands of our engineers
and
it's really different i mean then
what
different maybe startup small startups
or large extremely large companies offer
in a small startup you don't really see
definitely don't see these kind of
customers and in large companies you
usually don't have that much of an
impact so we're really in a unique
position to offer both
um and that's
that's on top of you know the usual
everyone's working or everyone says that
they're working with the top
technological stack and all of that and
they're the best researchers and best
everything
so
when i say that we are working with the
top technological stack and you know
bleeding edge and
everything along that that's fine and
it's true but it's not a differentiator
at the end of the day
the differentiation at least in my mind
comes from what you do and how you
impact everything around you and uh
that's why safe reaches is an amazing
place that's so
tell me a little bit about uh safebreach
and the and i know i know that you're
doing some incredibly interesting
research i know bits and pieces from
stories of from my friends that they
would tell me you know over a beer but
you know
what what is safe breaches mission in
the world and where where are you
positioned today
excellent so um
an area called breach and attack
simulations uh was uh formed mainly uh
by safebreach
safe breaches um
founders this is uh an extremely
important area in which
companies
understand
what's going on in their uh security
ecosystem
for example in
cesar's all around the world they
you know that they received a lot of
money in order to purchase a lot of uh a
software in order to make their
companies um
not susceptible to uh to attack which is
nice and and they do that and everyone's
happy but at the end of the day
when something goes wrong in the world
they look for jays in the world or any
other cv that you can think of
and they do happen
when these come out when
they are asked are you are we are we in
the clear are we okay they don't know
they
they don't know for sure and that's
where we come in we actually um do the
tests do the
entire scenario we try to think as if
hackers do in order to
um assess
the
um the completeness of your solutions
and there are several layers one is we
try to figure out whether it's possible
or not to do i don't know any type of
attack
um and
then there's another
another area of figuring whether what
you purchased in order to stop
those types of attacks from happening
uh whether those are the runs that have
been configured correctly to be
stopping that so we have that in place
as well
and uh
as far as we're concerned when you look
at the outputs of what we do you have a
complete a more holistic idea of where
you are and you can decide what you want
to do with that information do you want
to
prevent
prevent people from accessing your
extremely important database that's
that's important maybe you don't really
care if someone accesses a different
area that's okay
but it's something that you need to be
aware of once you
once you install all of your uh network
securities and other security measures
and right now what they do is they
install it they configure it
it's supposed to be doing what they're
what they thought they do
but it's hope and hope's not really a
strategy at the end of the day
you really need to know and that's where
we come in and we
we we provide you with that information
and
there's one really really important
thing that safebeach does really really
well
and that's the ability to respond to
um
ongoing threats that come in and they
come in all the time
we have an sla well
24 hours it's usually much less
when a cv comes out and then our amazing
researchers they come in they assess the
information and they are able to use our
proprietary technology in order to
provide customers with the relevant
playbooks that help them figure out are
they
susceptible to this or or not
and that's uh that's really important i
mean at the end of the day that's what
customers need they want
and uh and that's where we are wow i it
sounds like you know the both the the
variability of the variance in in the
types of things that you have to deal
with on a day-to-day basis coupled with
the very quick feedback loop that you
would get from customers being very
attentive to the you know the immediate
actions that you can take to help them
you know in a crisis situation and i'm
sure that you know there's products that
give a delightful moment you know when
people want it or feel like it there are
other products that help customers or
help companies emerge from a crisis
situation and and i'm always inspired to
i don't know about companies that are
that are helping mitigate some of these
things that a lot of people also don't a
lot of entities don't really know how to
understand and don't even know how to
tackle themselves and and so i think
it's just it's extremely interesting
what you're doing with the safe breach
and and again i've i have so many great
friends that you know that are there and
they have such a great time so thank you
very very much for for taking the time
to to come here i i do have
another question for you and i want you
to go back a little bit a really long
time before you were an engineer before
all of these incredible positions
middle school seventh grade
what are you what are you
curious about what what's your passion
that during that time of your life
it's um
it's going to be really uh
a bit cheesy i think
computers
i have to say seven years old
not seven you said seventh grade seven
years old
so no no seventh grade you're right
you're right
yeah seventh grade yeah
um
but
mainly because i think that uh
looking back i mean these are such
versatile
um
instruments that allow you to do so much
in
and it was really fascinating to me i
mean it was really amazing that you can
get so much done
obviously play
computer games but also
get work done on them and
you know words and
everything
write books
all that stuff on a single
instrument it was amazing to me
i love it you don't thank you so so much
for taking the time to join me here
i really appreciate it and continue
doing amazing things with safebreach and
anywhere else and
thank you very much for the last 20
minutes of inspiration i appreciate it
have a great day bye you too bye-bye